The Joe Rogan experience.
I like to tell people my paths don't define me.
It refined me. Oh, I got you see,
because it's so much that I see.
I have four now so much that I
see that I've seen, I've witnessed, I've done myself personally,
or, you know, I've been very, very close to the action.
And I'm an odd man. I say, well, you know, if you do this,
then more likely this will be the outcome.
That's why I never joined a gang because I was like,
not that I didn't do anything wrong,
but I felt like if I'm going to do something wrong, I trust me to not snitch.
Yeah. So best reason for it.
I'm going to tell you a story that I tell your story. Never, never told public.
In the
mid eighties,
there was some cat killings in Houston that it was killing cab cab
drivers. Right?
The guys who were involved, who started it,
came to my house first to get me to go with them, to hit a lick.
We pour we in the hood. You know, like everybody needs money.
Some of us we're not going to eat. You know,
if we don't go out there and kill something, not literally kill a person,
but kill something, you know, so that we can, that we can, um,
nourish our bodies. Right. It came to me,
Hey man, look, we finna go do this one on.
And I look out and I see light is the dude that wanted to catch that's,
you know, in the neighborhood, that tough guy.
And then I S I look out and I see like three other dudes with him, high hell,
nah, that's too many dudes. Now, if,
if he wouldn't have had that many people with him,
I probably would have went with him.
If it would've just been him and another cat, alright,
I probably would have went. I don't know.
But he had like three other dudes with him. And
the next morning I hear a cab driver,
old black dude in the neighborhood. Well, he wasn't from the neighborhood,
but they killed him in the neighborhood. A,
the elderly dude. And they only took like 30 something bucks, man.
Uh, and so I know that's what happened, right?
So then over the next, like maybe three weeks, four more cab drivers get killed.
I know I'm pretty good. I got a pretty good idea.
Who's doing this, right?
Because I'm not the only one that knows it's other
people that know these guys and they're talking.
So there's murmurs in the streets
about this happening. So then they get caught up.
And each of these guys,
they end up with the one that got the less years was like 15 years.
All of these guys were miners, except that the main one,
they were 14 to like 19 years old.
So they ended up with a minimum 15 years.
And then the one that got to max was like 40 years.
So my life would have been very, very much different.
And I walked out that door that night.
Wow. That's amazing.
Yes. I can see a lot of things happening. Like I can see, you know,
like experience, you know,
I can S I can see a lot of things happening from my own experience,
but other people's experience too.
And I personally do believe that experience is not the best teacher,
other people's experiences, the best teacher.
Because if I see you go
out and if you walk around the corner
and you come back running back bleeding
profusely, Oh man, these guys around come at me, man,
why would I run my silly around the corner?
Right. What's going to happen to me. Right? What what's likely to happen to me?
What could happen to me if I go around that same corner
next?
So, no, I'm not going around the corner. I'm going in the opposite direction.
In fact, give them by me, man.
Cause they might come stab you again and get me while I'm with you.
Yeah, I think you're right. I think you can learn from both,
but you can learn the terrible lessons from other people that are having to do.
Without ever having to do it.
Then you stick your hand in the fire and it burned you.
Why the hell would I stick mine in that fire?
And let it burn me unless I want to be burned. So that's why,
you know, these, these, the gang thing. I, you know,
I could never get with it. I've never been a gang member.
So I don't know what these guys be thinking. I don't know what they,
what they be thinking, man,
but I just don't see an upside to it. I just,
it has a terrible retirement plan.
You know.
Most of the dunes, most of the dudes are killed before they're 30,
or maybe they have a extensive criminal history.
Their,
their opportunities are severely limited because of the record.
People afraid to do business with them. You know, it's, it's just way too much.
And I just feel, I just figured, like, you know, well,
I'm just going to go ahead and avoid it. Plus I'm a black man in America.
It's all kind of ways to get killed in here.
It's all kind of ways to die already. Right? Okay. Besides like,
you know, like natural stuff, like natural death, diabetes,
cancer, lupus, uh, you know, obesity,
all these types of things, right. That can kill you stroke,
you got accidents. You know, I get hit by a car or something like that.
Uh, you got domestic disputes.
Why would I say, you know what?
I need one more month thing. The guy helped me rush.
I got to get that baby. I gotta get that. I'm going to join a gang.
I'm trying to eliminate the things that can,
that can kill me. I'm trying to avoid those types of things.
Why would I walk right in to something.
Again, a lot of people do, like what, what, where did you get the wisdom? Like,
you've the way you think right now, this have you always thought this way,
where you plot ahead and look at things like you're playing 3d chess.
I did to an extent, but I got a lot better at it in my twenties,
like late twenties, I got really better.
And the reason why I say that is because the tricky part about it is that like,
there are dudes that are my age that tell me, man,
you was like a big brother to me. You know,
because I've been knowing them since we were like teenagers or
early twenties or whatever.
And I've always been just a few steps ahead and, and,
you know, seeing what was going on, you know, watching, you know, so,
but I still had some things that, that I had to learn, uh,
primarily conflict resolution, conflict resolution.
It should be taught in schools. I agree. Uh,
Americans have a big problem with conflict resolution.
It should be taught in schools.
Any of you politicians out there y'all want to work on a bill with me,
come on with it. I'm down.
Conflict resolution should be taught in schools because I remember being on
stage man.
And somebody would like heckle, like,
and it'd be like, Oh, it would be a dude,
always a dude heckled like, ah, man,
y'all dada talking crazy for no reason.
And I would jump off stage, knock them out,
get back on stage and finish the show. You know,
I would do stuff like that. I mean, once we were in Jackson,
Mississippi, let me see, uh, statue limited.
Okay. I'm past. Yeah. Okay. We're in Jackson,
Mississippi and the promoter owes us our backend.
You know, they pay you the front end, you know, for signing the contract,
agreeing to do the show, then you show up, they pay you the rest
we get there. It's caused everywhere. It's caused lining the streets.
It's there all on the grass.
We noticed B and for all it is,
I don't care how many soda shows you do.
You love to see the people turn out and you go like, wow.
So this is one of those nights I manage our road manager.
Chief comes back to the limo and it's, you know, this was long ago.
Long time ago, people were still, we were still riding in limousine. So
I manager comes over. He say, he said, Hey man.
He said he ain't got all the money, promote it. Don't have all the money.
I said, what you mean? Ain't got all the money, man. All these people out here,
man. We like, man. Yeah. We,
I grabbed my cousin Dre and we go in there,
say, man, you going to come off that money?
Or
at first he chuckled
say, man, a Blick. He'll bring that money back here. And dah, dah, dah.
He gave us the money.
We came back to the limo, even careful with us, even
just the emotion, got the money.
We got the money and now everything is good.
Went on the stage and did the show and then left.
This is me like again, Cabo, Western days. Right?
Not really taking like, like it all kinds of things that could happen with that.
And that situation. Sure.
Like going back on the stage, like, listen,
just going back on the stage, backup, just
taking that money like that in the first place, you know, that's the case.
That could be a case. Okay. Then you go on stage.
You do a show this though we're in his hometown. He could be rallying.
We come out of this hole. I'm not thinking on that type of level. I'm like,
he violated you get this and that's it.
And it's whatever you want to get it for now. Oh, uh,
in that exact same situation, uh,
I would try to convince him to pay up.
Like he still wouldn't get away with it, but I would just do it differently.
Yeah. Hello? I get it. Yeah. Yeah.
I still, he would have to pay up. I mean, there's a long history of promoters.
Not paying people. They must pay. They must pay. They must pay.
Because what you don't want to do is you
don't want to have like,
be in a situation where people owe you money and
look, man, if it's an honest, day's work for an honest,
day's pay nothing more, nothing less.
Episodes of the Joe Rogan experience are now free on Spotify. That's right.
They're free from September 1st is December 1st.
They're going to be available everywhere.
But after December 1st they will only be available on Spotify,
but they will be free. That includes the video. The video will also be there.
It'll also be free. That's all we're asking you. Just go download Spotify,
Bubba.
No.